that's an old picture if you don't
realize hey what's going on everybody
it's Bill Burns time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast I thought I'd wear a
nice blue shirt to bring up my eyes but
with my pasty complexion and the
lighting in here I'm just looking a
little overcast and um even I'm just
checking in on you I have a special
guest and speaking oh they brought it
down a little bit a little warmer light
for me speaking of uh lack of pigment uh
my guest today is uh one of my favorite
comedians one of the funniest guys out
there for the longest time uh sells a
zillion tickets from Indiana that's
right ladies and gentlemen with a new
special called Dark pale available now
on Amazon Amazon Amazon
The One and Only Jim Gaffigan thank you
buddy I feel like we should shake him
how are you sir I'm good to see you I'm
good I like that I wish I had glasses no
I mean I wish I didn't have glasses I
need glasses I need try you don't have
glasses I have the far ones yeah for
when I watch hockey and I sit on my
couch and I want to be able to see fully
what's I can still see the puck by the
way all these [__] [__] even with
my eyes messed up I still know where it
is yeah how about guessing maybe the guy
everybody's paying attention to maybe he
has it is usually a good place to live I
don't like how there's always smudge you
you know like I don't know what if it's
like eyebrow dandruff but after a couple
hours it's just covered in goo my
glasses oh well I would say that's how
you live in your life right what it is
no you know what it is is you never left
the clubs even though you're playing all
the big places you still go to the gym
and you still work out I always see you
work whenever I come you know out here
or New York you're always working out
you're in those dirty filthy clubs I
love it and it just gets on you right
it's like but what if you didn't
do stand up right if you didn't have
that outlet I I don't know what
I I don't think it would be good like I
think mentally I need it to get that
endorphin not just necessarily the
laughter but like the Fulfillment of a
new line a new joke
that's that keeps the endorphins going
right but I think there's something
about you guys who grew up out in the
midwest there's something about
you know
just in the winter time I always bring
this up when the crops are cut down yeah
and that overcast gray sky meets that
dead Earth yeah it just does something
you guys you guys all kind of have that
serial killer Vibe like you could go you
could go
yeah you know come on pot Kettle what
you're saying you don't come across like
a serial killer no I come like I come
off like a hot head who's gonna get
killed in a bar fight I'm gonna hit my
head off a curb I don't I don't have
that Rusty farming tools in the
background I would have you Midwest
people have like I would have a sling
blade like that [__] I would have I
would murder people in an interesting
way it wouldn't be
it would be kind of it would you like if
you discovered oh Jim Gaffigan's been
killing people it would there would be
an interesting thing like oh my God he
chokes them and then he jerks off on him
or something like well that's syrup the
Syracuse are the artists they are of
murderers they're the they're they're
kind of the stand-up comedians of
criminals right the serial killers they
are the stand-up comedians they're
they're kind of they're unrecognized
they kind of they work their way up they
work alone
right they serial killers rather I mean
outside of the Nazis they they don't
really work in groups they're usually so
low they they often you know like if
they're you know Ted Bundy he traveled
he would go on tour the best ones you
don't really know their names right the
hacks usually you know like they're
always trying to like tease the police
so they get their name out they're like
you know who's the hack was that BTK
killer right because he named himself
and then he was trying to get all his
attention well he also retired and then
he came back and then he got busted that
was his ego that was him kind of like he
you know like stand up you have to
consistently do it like when people take
like 20 years off and then they come
back and do us but it's always it's like
when Jordan went to the Wizards right so
he came back and he was BTN but he
wasn't K and right well he you know God
is you know the serial killer thing is
why do we people love by the way women
seem to love murderers
like my wine I'm fascinating right like
they're all against like rude Behavior
but like my wife can't get enough of
that Dateline show right yeah my wife
watches that the amount of times I've
gone to sleep where I just hear that it
was a quiet town right things like this
weren't supposed to happen right they
were in love until or so it appeared or
so it appeared yeah no that why is that
what's you know my wife claims that she
watches it because she thinks what would
I do in that situation and like you know
what I mean I I mean I guess I I for a
while was watching Those Behind the
Scenes prison things trying to come up
with a plan of what I would do before I
finally came to the obvious answer which
was I would get raped repeatedly
that I think we
uh I I don't know I mean at the end of
the day I mean you can't go from [__]
yeah
is that what you would want to happen I
mean it's a combination of both no it's
just but what if I I call it being a
realist like every guy thinks that like
I have like I I spent one night in jail
never in prison I got arrested for
drinking and driving I had to sell to
myself I'd have to fight anybody off so
like you can't go that's what always
fascinates me with these [__] idiots
who kill their spouse it's like you
barely even cheated on your taxes and
now you're gonna try to get away with
the most difficult thing to get away
with where you're you're you're going to
be one of the first suspects right who
look to profit right right do you have
life insurance by the way because the
second you get life insurance you've
you've you oh yeah you've put up a
[__] a green light on your forehead
but what if you got to prison I mean I
feel like I if I went to prison like I'm
not gonna go but if I got to prison I
feel like I wouldn't get raped they be
like uh you know what we don't nothing
personal you would because you look like
a child molester no they wouldn't they
wouldn't they wouldn't rape me and then
I'd be all insecure and then I'd be like
oh nobody wants to rape me that it would
be like but like there would be like
there there's probably some people that
are like oh well at least I'll get raped
in prison and then they don't get raped
because you know how like in high school
I would make a shank and then I would
just stab myself you but like in high
school when you look back at your
yearbook and you'll look at girls and
you'll be like they were kind of cute
but like that probably happens in prison
like there are probably people in prison
where you think oh that guy would get
raped but he doesn't get raped because
like in the social thing people like oh
they're annoying or
is this making any sense I mean I don't
I mean I don't I watched enough of those
that I I realized that I still don't
yeah I don't I just remember seeing that
I just saw a couple of guys where they
they are just so far removed like their
mindset it's just like the game that
they're playing like this guy well this
guy was just talking about something
that he did to his cellmate and
he he was he was talking like it wasn't
even him who did it going yeah we don't
know I was just like this guy is [__]
yeah crazy you know I mean I remember
when I would get a divorce
yeah and you lose all your money but
like the uh like I remember watching Oz
because I I couldn't watch us I've had a
lot of storylines where I'm like
what are we supposed to root for that
guy you know like they were all kind of
I I couldn't watch that show it was very
weird because it was in the same kind of
era as
uh as Sex in the City so I'm like is
this was sex in the cities for the women
is Oz for the guys it's so weird
that show it's just like I don't want
his I don't want to see that I don't
want to watch people doing that to each
other and it's just like yeah that's
just too weird yeah right that's just
like I don't know that was ahead of its
time that was very ahead of it there had
to be something else I feel like our sex
in the city is uh is when they do you
know uh like behind the lines or
whatever or some sports team or
something like that right they go into
the lot that's like yeah our Real
Housewives yeah I see the coaches giving
speeches and [__] like I feel like
that's we gotta let you go and then yes
sir thank you sir like that's the drama
no that was tough I love that kid
keep your head up let's go to the buffet
yeah it's it's just so weird no or I
would say like uh Fast and Loud Like car
shows where they're making cars I find
those like I like you know watching
people that know how to like build [__]
yeah
um
I'm into that type of [__] I guess that
that would be like our Sex in the City
there has to be something else I'm just
so relieved that I I love gardening I
don't want to try and sound all man
that's another red flag of what of a
serious color yeah no gardening I
thought that it was I think that would
indicate that I'm 90. but like or it
would also indicate that you know if
you're digging a hole in your backyard
no one's going oh he's just gardening
it's this area is very fertile is your
wife still on that trip
she's been gone for a while now
but um taking care of her mother I I
love gardening I think you should try
gardening but like that is I don't know
how I got on this topic but I love like
we went to a prison rape prison rape to
uh locker rooms to gardening to
gardening it's pretty logical but it is
you should check it out it's very
isolating you do it by for yourself
there's surprises at the end kind of
like oh look a rattlesnake no it's like
you grow you plant a one potato and then
like three months later you come back
and there's like
20 potatoes or there's none that has to
be exciting though wait a minute 20
potatoes that has to be [__] amazing
it is exciting you want everyone in your
family to say this is the best guy no no
my I torture my kids I'm like at dinner
I'll be like you know I probably get the
best Garden anywhere and they're like
yeah right yeah dad you know the salad I
grew this lettuce and they're I'm you
know it's but like if I'm gonna be oh
here's what I said it is that I'm glad
I'm into gardening because when I scr
Doom scroll
on my Instagram I'm just looking at
gardening videos and it's like oh here's
a a a a hack on how to grow celery it's
like I'm not I'm not like you I'm not
looking at porn I'm a good man
all right guilty is charged right now I
I what I look at now is the amount of
time that I spent on the phone I I don't
I try to stay the [__] away from that
thing I delete apps do you delete apps
no because I always think this has to be
a reason I downloaded that thing I just
don't remember what it is so I just
leave it alone I've actually started
reading again oh yeah yeah which is
hilarious that is fun it's not like deep
reading what are you reading right now
I'm I'm finishing this book uh called
billionaire Boogeyman that a friend of
mine a comedian Todd Parker wrote and
I'm actually reading it going like this
could actually be a really good [__]
movie really and what's the premise of
it uh just like Illuminati level rich
people that know all the secrets of the
world and their kidnapping prostitutes
and they may or may not own a Bigfoot
that eats the prostitutes while the rich
people watch
[Music]
you know what I love about it is that
you know comedians do you have to have a
certain suspic you have to have
curiosity a suspicion and then there is
paranoia and then and then all the way
over is there is the conspiracy theorist
like you definitely like I'm more
curiosity you're kind of like you're not
full conspiracy but you're definitely
you're like you would never do 23 in May
you would you're highly you're pretty
suspicious uh you how how many
conspiracy like do you believe they
landed on the moon
uh I don't know what happened do you
believe that uh every because this is a
common thing do you believe that every
rich person has gained that success no
no by taking advantage of poor people no
because that's a big thing yeah that's
why the lack of empathy for people in
that submersible ignore it [__] those
[__] people man well but by the way
do you think what are your views of
billionaires like do you think that I
just think it depends on how you got it
if you did it in an underhanded way even
if you're a millionaire I don't respect
you but if you're a billionaire if
you're like [__] Tyler Perry he's a
billionaire I'm not mad at him because
he [__] figured out Medea is it Medea
media media and how to like get himself
on the other side of the desk to
eliminate people putting hands in his
pockets like as as an artist looking at
that guy I yeah look at him like wow how
did you do that so I don't I don't look
at people like I mean if you uh
yeah I know I don't I don't yeah but the
thing but there's a stereotype there's a
stereotype of
uh conspiracy theorists they always go
to the Moon thing do you think it's made
out of cheese do you think we think
there was a Sound Stage no I I don't I
don't think well there is something you
know like I kind of I did think the NBA
was fixed and oh you did and I was right
I think there's a script and all that
like that NFL script thing like that was
a big thing on Twitter like well I do
think that the fact that they all call
themselves entertainment leagues because
then if somebody actually does fix a
game
that they can't for some reason the
government gets involved I don't know
why you can turn our [__] food supply
into poison that's fine they don't get
involved but if if you take steroids and
hit too many home runs all of a sudden
you know or or a [__] Lance Armstrong
the Department of Justice gets involved
in a [__] about a bike race in in
France I think it's just all a bunch of
oh look at this over here oh who is this
guy and then meanwhile you can do all of
this [__] horrific [__] as a
corporation and as long as your help
funding their campaigns they do look the
other way I don't think that that's a
conspiracy and I also don't think it's
it's wild that all of these sports
leagues are now in bed with gambling
companies I think that's a problem I
think that's a big that was like the
number that was like the number one rule
that's Pete Rose that's like Peter Rose
was like right man of his time and he
was you know they're like no no Pete
Rose is gone forever and now there's a
couple players that have been betting
that are like well a couple games and
Pete Rose I just knew the guy in the
Falcons did it no there was there was uh
there's someone on the Colts that that
is gonna miss some games but yeah it is
we like because they can't punish him
too bad because then they're telling
fans that this is a bad thing to do they
I mean they basically made
a deal with the devil and I'm saying
this as I advertise Sports gambling on
this podcast well yeah no it's and you
know it's like I I like Kevin Hart but
like he's you know like the there is
something about those draftking things
that I don't I don't have any problem
with it but you can blame Kevin Hart for
sports I blame him for uh the the Mobile
Wireless Monopoly that exists and and
for 5G giving people cancer no I don't
blame him for anything he's just he like
Target he wants to be a billionaire like
of all our friends
and comedian peers like Kevin wants to
be a billionaire I don't know how I got
on that topic but let me explain this
here's here's where I'm worried about
sports getting in bed with gambling some
of it is they need advertisers right and
they also they they like the taste of
money like I don't know how much cadell
makes a year but 30 million and
but how much does the league make you
know I mean it's like what what should
his cut be versus Ted sarandos or that
guy who uh you know zazlov made 400
million I don't know it's like but the
thing that worries me about the sports
betting who the [__] is zazlov he's the
guy Warner
uh a Warner discovery
he's the one uh that but like you know
those guys they any bad move they make
they blame on their shareholders but
then for some reason shareholders aren't
upset when they give themselves 100 200
million dollar bonus at the end of the
year I mean that's also like Goodell
that's legalized stealing he's being
paid 30 million I have to think the
owners are like how much do we make oh
we made 800 million I don't care give
him 30. yeah I mean
uh I don't look I I don't I don't know
how this [__] works but I I do know that
it's a business yeah it's a business and
I feel like the way the NBA I'm not
gonna get I've talked about this too
many times it's just and and what just
pissed me off was when they actually
showed that a ref was was fixing games
they were able to friend I was one guy
Bill just what really Lee Harvey
officiator
wow no but like that if you actually
watch there's a documentary on the
Donahue guy like I actually think that
while he was fixing games and I think he
was doing with other referees I mean he
can't just as one official starts
shaving points and the other guys on
your coaching officiating team aren't
aware of what you're doing
so at the very least I think you
shouldn't have you should have
investigated those guys I also think
while simultaneously he was fixing games
literally I feel like starting those
guys were massaging certain
organizations with the most Stars slash
the best ratings I mean they look at
their [__] ratings it's the bigger
markets are going to give more viewers
yeah so they're going to get their calls
so I don't think they literally said
this Dave is going to play this team so
this team wins I think they just they
they made sure that the the highest
rating Getters had the best opportunity
the most grease slide
to get there and um
you know I mean
that I just want to just think what's
funny is all Laker fans have is what
about the time when [__] what's his
face wanted to come here and they
blocked the trade it's like all right
one out of 700 000 [__] free agents
that went your way they didn't let you
get it was Chris Paul they wouldn't let
him come there and they got all [__]
up and I don't know why that I still
don't know why they blocked that
um because they allowed all of these
other ones so for the while it wasn't
like competition I'm doing it again
about the gambling thing is my 12 year
old is actually pretty good at
basketball and he I said he's gambling
he's pretty good at it well that's the
thing it's like he you can't watch
the NBA Finals without being kind of
like gamble gamble gamble and so he's
like hey can we gamble on the next game
I'm like no I mean granted it's the only
addiction I don't have but like I'm like
oh you you're one of those guys that I
what what did I do you're not drinking
[__] no I drink but like I have a
tendency to like addictive behavior
that's what I have I'm not a full-on but
I'm I'm three quarters there well you
know like my whole thing with you like
food's been a thing for you food is a
big thing every so you look great right
now like you've dropped like 30 pounds
or something no some of it's I'm wearing
a coat but uh
but you know what it is a red flag when
a guy's wearing a coat this is July but
the uh but the no like here's my whole
thing and I was trying to explain this
to my kids I'm like and by the way this
is I I did this play and and he won't
care Jason Patrick is this uh this
friend of mine who's like who enjoys
drink he goes he goes you don't want to
be in a position where you can't drink
some people just are like I'm done I
think you were like I'm done yeah but
like some people are like they have to
stop and so he's kind of like he's
somebody who's like
loves to have a beer like when we did
that that Broadway play we would go out
every night and he'd be like the thing
is is you have to temper it because you
don't want to get to the point where you
can't ever have it again
and so that's because you know if you
have an addictive thing so it's like you
gotta no you gotta know you're I mean do
half a shot no no that's it that's
that's
I think that's the difference between
someone who has a problem doesn't and I
I think like look I think that I could
you know if I didn't have it at home
but I just know that it it just would it
just kept always just kept getting to
that point of me being like I gotta I
gotta I gotta cut back I need to stop
for a while and I just I got sick of
doing that yeah I'm drinking I'm not
drinking I'm drinking I'm not drinking
then when I just quit the last time I
was just like I just don't want to go
through
that first [__] two weeks of not
drinking before I just don't give a [__]
anymore just trying to get through that
like I'm doing that with like cigars for
the umpteenth time yeah
where all I need to do is just get 10
days in and then I never need to have
another one right so I'm six days in now
and now it's just starting it's like a
relationship they just they fade away
and you move on to somebody else
and I feel like and you eventually don't
even miss it like when I've been eating
really healthy
I mean this is 20 years ago but like I
didn't eat Doritos and you wouldn't even
want to eat a Dorito when you're eating
healthy all right everybody it's Helix
everybody Helix Helix who gives a [__]
can't do it that way all right it's
Helix everybody Helix uh it's Helix
sleep the Helix lineup offers 20 unique
mattresses introducing uh the
award-winning Luxe collection
the newly released Helix yeah there was
a there was a mattress award show and
they won the coveted Luxe collection
um Elite collection a mattress designed
for Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids so how will
you know know which Helix mattress works
best for you and your body will take
advantage of the Helix sleep quiz and
find your perfect mattress
as soon as you can where the hell am I
find your perfect mattress I try to do
eye contact in under two minutes and
your personalized mattress is shipped
straight to your door free of charge
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than getting on
it and starting [__] no then getting on
it and sleeping on it in your own home
that's why they offer 100 night trial
and a 10 to 15 year warranty to try it
out man however that whatever that means
to you and your new Helix mattress plus
enhanced cooling features to keep you
from overheating at night if you're
stealing from the company you'll sleep
better and if your spine needs some
extra TLC they got you uh every Helix
mattress has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's the perfect combination of comfort
and support don't want to take my word
for it uh Helix has been awarded the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine it's even recommended by
a multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
go to helixsleep.com this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now Doritos is
one of the bigger lies of the last
century Doritos Doritos the dishwasher
the Doritos and disrupt I've never seen
that were the three biggest lies of the
20th century
dishwasher does not wash dishes it gets
some wet and it Heats them up if you
don't [__] pre-wash the hard [__]
you're gonna have a film I learned that
during the pandemic that uh just do the
[__] work just no no well you know
what you're not using the right
dishwasher because like I didn't realize
that you know like I was doing I was
cleaning up afterwards no it's cleaning
them it's cleaning them you've got a bad
dishwasher no you're an animal you're
yeah no I'm not saying you're gonna
leave like half spaghetti on a plate but
you do a quick rinse you wash it there
you go yeah if you do most of the job it
can finish disaster you see that's the
comedian point of view well that's what
it is yeah it's not the comedian point
of view it's the consumer point of view
it's it's [__] [__] and it's it's
for [__] lazy people that want to act
that just don't want to do the [__]
job and then what I hate is it's not
filled up you can't run it and then all
of these [__] your favorite mug to drink
coffee it's like held hostage for like
three [__] days in there until the
whole thing is filled up or they just
run it half full you're wasting [__]
water just wash them just do the [__]
job do it once and do it right don't
half-ass it then stick it in there for
three days and then it kind of does it
and then I get I gotta let me just
[__] go like that and I can put my
[__] Fruit Loops in here it's just
like just [__] just just do the job
just do it just do the [__] job do
your job Bill Belichick right there you
go do your [__] job how do you think
the Patriots are going to be this year
uh you know we had a great run 20
[__] years I think yeah I'm actually
yeah it's unbelievable okay and and Bill
Belichick is the greatest head coach
since Paul Brown literally changed the
[__] game okay
that is what it is they can say whatever
they want and all of that [__] and
it [__] happened and uh and it was
fun to watch and I'm
I'm actually looking forward to seeing
what Aaron Rodgers on the Jets is gonna
do to the bills did the Bills miss their
[__] window because this is not Brett
Favre of going to the Jets Aaron Rodgers
has at least at least three All-Pro
seasons in him I think if he has the
right people around him they got a great
defense yes he's going to come in there
and I think it this foregone conclusion
that it's the Bill's time
and does Josh Allen and all these guys
have enough to sketch the Super Bowl and
finally bring Buffalo that elusive Super
Bowl champion when we were kids it's
like Buffalo went four times in a row
and lost every time
um yeah it's just it was that was such a
horrible thing to watch because most
people lose in life and you just needed
to see that if you keep knocking on the
door you win and that was Mark Levy the
poor guy he he was just too nice
no but I remember watching it was just
brutal
well also the Vikings when we were kids
we went yeah we got very close well they
were also victim of steroids I mean the
other I mean like the Steelers were
coming in just [__] yeah and I think
that was yeah you know what else it was
a victim I was talking about this the
other day the Patriots should have
played him in Super Bowl 11 but we got a
[__] [__] call against the Raiders
and I just think the Patriots were a way
better matchup for the Vikings than the
Raiders the Raiders were [__]
lunatics I mean and the the game started
it was either Sammy white or Ahmad
Rashad I forget who came across the
middle and one of those guys docked to
death a [__] uh uh uh Jack Tatum just
[__] just laid the guy out like I was
just and it was that was the end I mean
I'm sort of romanticizing that one play
but they just made that statement and it
was just like uh
you know I'm not I said that's I
shouldn't say it this way because it
sounds like I'm taking away the Raiders
championships because I [__] love
those teams and I love all those guys
but um yeah we got [__] hosed on that
call
uh essentially when the game was over
and then but then they also delivered
you know after they got the the penalty
and uh I just think that the Vikings I
think they would have beat us it is I
mean the Vikings I feel like even when
farv was there they were like they're
gonna go this year and it just I mean
they also
that year there were 15-1 with Randall
Cunningham and Randy Moss right oh and
they were one of the most my favorite
thing of Randy Moss is the second he
would be like a yard and a half into his
pattern he would just go like he already
knew he had the guy beat he'd just go
like this and it didn't even look like
he was running Randy Moss like yeah you
know there's an argument where they were
you know Jerry Wright I think Jerry Rice
was the ultimate combination of talent
discipline running the pattern but blah
blah blah but it's just as far as like
you know you want to talk about a guy
just freestyling like beyond the game
Lawrence Taylor level changing the
position is without a doubt Randy Moss
like Randy Moss if somebody would just
sit across me and say I think Randy's
better than
um then Jerry Rice I mean I wouldn't
argue I was like I mean that's it's it's
different errors right you know so it's
but it's also like they were close
enough he kind of ended and then he came
in it wasn't like he played 30 years
after him but like
and just what the [__] they lost to the
Falcons who loses to the Falcons the the
the the the the NFL the drama like
that's where I'm so excited it's like so
like you know like the there are these
storylines of Aaron Rodgers and the Jets
and their defense and
and you know like even when the Rams
were kind of it was a stacked deck at
the beginning of that season when they
won the Super Bowl there was kind of
like but sometimes the chemistry doesn't
work yeah dude I mean it's like there
were so many years where like the chiefs
were uh
Schottenheimer like there were 15-1 and
they couldn't
make it through the playoffs so there is
so much drama and then there's the CH
because like even the Belichick thing
and the Belichick and the Brady thing
like who was more important to the the
the Empire and uh just it's it's every
year yeah but they never asked that
question that is like so the question of
sports writers who
they have no imagination they don't want
to keep writing the same story that
they're winning so then they try to like
they try to rip it down they build it up
and then they rip it down and then they
go were we fair to the Patriots that's
their final thing like they do that with
[__] everything they build it up they
rip it down and then they because that's
our soap opera that's that's what that's
what that's what football fans love they
love the NFL what I love and I love this
season of the NBA with the Nuggets
coming out of nowhere right is like you
got I feel like
if sports fans are gonna invest this
amount of money in this amount of motion
in that their their team should have a
shot like when Kobe gets drafted to the
[__] Hornets the league should have
been like no you're [__] playing
there and then they should have enjoyed
his talents rather than Beyond I'm not
[__] playing there I'm gonna go to
the [__] team that always wins like
that's a terrible message to send to the
people of Charlotte did with uh San
Diego right he was drafted by the
Chargers Elway did it with the Colts
yeah I think that that is a uh but I
will say this I kind of understand it in
football especially as a quarterback
because one of the worst things
you know to be is a highly touted
quarterback in an NFL draft because
you're going to go to the worst team
with no offensive line and if you don't
have a head coach and a GM and an owner
in place that is gonna you know like
look at what happened to Aikman he got
the [__] kicked out in the first couple
years and Jimmy Johnson came in and then
had like all those 300 Pounders in front
of him and he was able to perform at the
level that he could perform it but the
level of the beating that that guy took
in the beginning is just like
um you know I think some of that had to
do with probably Archie his dad who
played for the [__] Saints was just
like I can't watch my own no you're not
going there go to the charges during
this time where the charges are
um the mental grit that like these I
mean all those players but like that
quarterbacks because we don't know I
mean maybe maybe some people know more
than others but like we don't know what
uh you know like Joe burrow like his we
can see the accomplishment he's made in
Cincinnati but like we don't know where
he you know how much uh you know even
when Brady went down to Tampa where he
was like uh this is here this is here
you know like there is some kind of you
know when we get into a theater to do a
show we're like they're like yeah the
lights don't go down you're like no turn
them off turn them off all of them off
and you know and now I'm comparing
myself to Brady but like I was totally
on board but like the whole thing is
this but we don't really
know that like that mental grit and some
of it is impossible because there are
these great quarter remember there was a
quarterback that went to University of
Texas and he was playing for for the
Titans and he was pretty good and then
he just explained oh uh uh Vince Young
yeah like that that mental
grit or toughness that that's where I'm
impressed by burrow and that's actually
I think the Vince Young thing was he it
was almost like George Foreman George
Foreman said when Ali knocked him down
he said I could have got up I just never
been down before and I didn't know how
to do it and I think that there was with
Vince Young
I think what it was was they pulled him
out of a game and that had never
happened oh wow and he didn't know how
to deal with it or whatever but I mean
that [__] guy though but I mean
despite the ending of that guy's career
like that guy was a [__] great
quarterback and a winner and that that
you know that Rose Bowl performance and
everything I think yeah you know
if people just judge him by that like
that's one of those things where uh I
feel like when the the internet the the
uh the haters the haters come in and
they love to see somebody that was you
know oh my gosh you know we've all
clicked on that like 32 draft bus and
you just click through and it's just
like so you can see ads but you're like
oh yeah I remember that guy yeah but you
know what I always I always see myself
in that like when I watch Ryan Leaf have
the Meltdown I just like I've done that
to CVS
yeah no why can't you just tell me what
[__] aisle it said well by the way I
also feel uh an incredible empathy
because there's also something about
these guys
touching the Sun so like and and hear me
out here so like there is something
about like the success we've had and you
know it's
but like I've never maybe you've been on
the cover of Rolling Stone I've never
been on the cover of Rolling so like I
used to always think that I wanted that
but like there's part of
the and I'm talking about this level of
success where they touch the sun action
you're doing your sexy layout
s like this with your [__] legs
crossed behind Rolling Stone senior
maybe but no but like like the Lettermen
Jon Stewart Chappelle
um
uh Kobe like I think that level of where
you touch the sun I think that's really
hard to to go to keep some sense of
normal so like so like Johnny Manziel
it's like he obviously had problems but
he touched the Sun and so then it's like
you might as well be Mariah Carey when
you throw like when we throw a fit in
the CVS people are like oh that guy's a
comedian he's spazzing out or you know
he's doing a bit you know what I mean
but like when Mariah Carey loses her
[__] she's so [__] famous that people
are like either they ascribe it is she's
a diva or she's having a melta but am I
making sense about the people that like
if you get so famous I think you get
addicted to that level of Fame that's
where I think that people like we you
know stand-up comedians have uh you know
we we have created fulfillment on our
terms it's you know people have to show
up but like even if like half as many
people went to our shows next year as
went this year we'd still get that
fulfillment but if people what I'm
saying is if you were as am I making
sense I think you've been out in that
Garden a little too long with the
[__] I don't know where you're going
we were talking football you're like you
know [__] Mariah Carey no well I'm
talking about quarterbacks like
quarterbacks like back to the
quarterback the quarterbacks that like
you know Jay Cutler like like people
[__] on him it's like he took a team to
the Super Bowl he was you know but what
are they going to do look at their own
lives that critically that's what they
they exist to for people to do that you
know why I live my life Johnny Manziel I
just think every single day I am doing
something with my kids that's what that
is my day and I don't even think about
any of this other [__] I don't think
about all of that stuff that you just
thought about touching the Sun and how
do you handle this and Mariah Carey you
know and all that I don't think about
any of it no no well I mean I think
there's a maturity where you
or not and well we also know people that
like we're so super ambitious you could
actually feel them climbing up your back
using you I'm not saying that we were do
you know what I mean it's like no I have
no idea what that is yeah I'm joking
okay it's like you know what I do love I
will say this is this is this is some
locker room [__] here and I'm not gonna
name any names but you know what what
[__] is [__] hilarious to me and
one of my favorite things about being in
this business is knowing who's actually
[__] crazy and who isn't and what's
funny is they don't know so when
somebody is going on and on and on and
on what's funny is like when somebody's
[__] crazy and you know they're crazy
if you're in the public eye you don't
jump into that you don't like tweet out
hey just for the record everybody this
person is out of their [__] minds you
don't do that but then what happens is
because nobody does it people are
listening to it like it's sanity like
it's sane and you're just watching this
[__] snowball going down the hill and
like that to me is like uh
you know a side of the fun of of getting
to do this job is is sitting there the
big reveal at the end they were crazy
and we're like we are we always knew
that yeah yeah and I was just like yeah
that person is just out of their [__]
but my thing is like when they're
watching it I don't know how they don't
notice
you know what I mean like when they just
you know I like uh I don't want to give
away everybody but you know what I mean
you're just sit in there oh yeah like I
mean that is my pull up a [__] TV
tray and let's and you just get to watch
this the the spigot is just turned on
and they are just [__]
whatever what there is I mean Seinfeld
also talks about this it's like you know
like the big thing of today he's like
we'll see in five years you know I mean
like he's you know in five years what
because there is this great sifting he
always says that the comedy ecosystem
yeah because I'm not just talking about
kamis I'm just talking about
whatever anyone from a talking head on
news on a news program to a [__]
whatever somebody that acts or whatever
like there's just people that you just
know like oh that person's oh they're
out of their [__] mind and they they
just they threw an assistant out of a
moving car and blah blah blah and then
they're like it's gonna you know what we
need to do in society Steven you're just
going like this is like the [__] this is
the best show on TV that people don't
even know is the show right
um that is one of my uh what am I not
saying that I am not uh you know I
actually talked about global warming on
my last on my last podcast and while I
was talking about my flight getting
canceled again and just saying [__] it
I'm gonna blow all my gig money on a on
a private jet which I didn't do but I
would have if it was available like I
was having a [__] temper tantrum so
I'm literally going like they're not
even paying attention to global warming
then I'm just like burn up the sky with
[__] leaded gas just for me you know
you know it's I I think uh in in my a
new special plug plug is yes on Amazon
on Amazon dark pale I had uh material
about global warming and I thought it
was so in you know like when you tour
around with material
and you can feel the audience uh
kind of noddle there's sometimes there's
accepting of a premise and then
sometimes there's people in the audience
that are like well I don't agree with
that fact but I like you I'll go along
with you do what I mean and you know
having I have material on global warming
a little bit and and there is part of me
it's like I don't know I have no idea
I'm just no you have to perform from
that place but like but the but the
interesting thing is like when you get a
sense from people in the audience where
you know sometimes like I'll do material
about religion and the audience I'll get
a sense from some people in the audience
like yeah there's there's no God and
then there's some people in the audience
like okay yeah there is a God you know
the the interesting thing is that like
with global warming there's a lot of
people that are like in in my audience
or at my shows that I get a sense where
they're saying all right I don't believe
in global warming but all he hear you
out on these jokes
which I think is interesting yeah I mean
I don't
yeah I mean it's just there's just
nothing you can do so that is the fun of
doing the road like I uh
I got a bit that I've been doing lately
talking about the clan and you can kind
of tell how racist the area is
it's you know some places you go to are
just like wow
yeah and then you bring you bring but
sometimes they're just like listening or
whatever but like I think as long as you
do what you what you said where you're
just like look I don't [__] know this
is what I think but I I don't ever want
to be like
well I also like this you know ramming
the the oh yeah the these are facts yeah
these are facts because uh I'm the one
with the microphone and therefore I know
[__] the right thing or whatever yeah
yeah no I think that there is also and I
also want a diversity of opinion I mean
that's you know with the country getting
divide I mean at Fourth of July I had
at my house Ted Alexandra who is an
Occupy Wall Street guy and Tom shallou
who literally works for Fox News and
they were there with their wives and
their kids and it was fun
and I miss that I mean some of it is
comedians we are such an Eclectic group
of Misfits but you like having that
diversity of opinion yeah right
What wave is boring that's why I never
understood like comedians I mean
remember for a while there was that
badge of honor that you were walking the
crowd and we went on stage in like three
quarters of the crowd left and it's like
well now the Fun's over yeah the only
people left are the ones that agree with
you it's just like the fun is
they don't agree with you but you you
say just enough that it pisses him off
but not enough that makes him leave so
they actually hear you out and you can
entertain them with it you can also or
annoy the [__] out of them and then it
becomes like this fun thing but once
they get up and take their ball and go
home
which I have to tell you though is like
the most childish
[__] thing ever would be like you
know I I can see if you leave because it
sucks
I always yeah yeah this movie sucks
let's get out of here or this person's
[__] boring but if it's just
literally like you were laughing and
everything was going good and then all
of a sudden you know
whatever trash women like I always do or
whatever now and I got a me feminism and
you walk out it's like you're you're a
baby
yeah no it is we should give you a
rattle when you walk out the door no
it's gonna offend you well I think some
some of that is
uh people want to they want to feel
empowered and I guess they're leaving
and they feel empowered right I actually
when I see people do that I actually
think like wow you are more sick in the
head than I am I'm so sick that I needed
to get on a stage and have people say
yeah we like you you're cool but you're
[__] like my ego never went to the point
that I thought that if I got up and
walked out
the rest of the room was going to follow
me or they were going to care
what were we like that whole like eye of
like you know like that that white glove
like you slap them across the face and
you've you've uh you know somehow
insulted their family crest with your
[__] joke by the way I do I mean I do
these very vanilla
um CBS Sunday commentaries and they're
fun you know like I'll write them in a
half an hour I'll have an idea I'll go
in and I'll record a couple and they're
really kind of
I do more of an orange shirt no but like
they're they're really kind of like I
don't like summer I don't you know like
it's just a mini rant right
and they're all done in jest and they're
done
for like 9 30 in the morning you know
what I mean so it's like after like
they've interviewed Richard Marx then I
go on and I talk about like I complain
about it Andy Rooney type yeah right
there are people always every Sunday on
Twitter Furious Furious
so I'll have a thing like one of my
prefaces was like I you know I respect
people that don't have kids but uh men
that like Father's Day it was the father
I was just gonna say that was was that
topic gets people going and and because
I did the whole thing of like on
Father's Day it was like uh men that
don't have children which is many
comedians right many of our friends and
I said uh you know uh what but what
about them on Father's Day what do we
call them besides lucky you know
relaxed and then I said and then I said
you know I uh I think and and some men
choose to not be involved in a child so
I I did it purposely to not alienate
people some people struggle with getting
pregnant and stuff like that but some
men but you can choose to be involved in
a child's life so I say some men choose
to not be involved in a child's life and
and I respect that but you know like
Bill Maher I don't think they should be
considered adults I think that you know
like that was that was the observation
and it's obviously done ingest right
because I am jealous and I'm sure
there's moments as much as we love our
kids it's like [__] I wish that you know
because you can't watch Sunday football
like you used to probably you want to
have some interaction with your children
right
or maybe you'd still do yeah I know I
love my kids but they're six and three
so it's like I don't want to miss like a
moment I don't have that and it's also
like yeah but I also like
um what fascinates me is people that
have children that can't accept people
that don't have children and are happy
about it and it's just like do you
realize what they did for society the
amount of people that don't want kids
and get pressured into it and now
they're they're raising this kid that
they don't want the kid's gonna sense
that and then when they grow up they can
have all these [__] issues and
everybody's gonna have to deal with it
like if you don't want kids you don't
have it that's [__] great yeah
there's too many people anyway and if
you don't if you don't want to have kids
don't have kids I think it's great but I
don't understand why people get all up
in somebody else's decision like it's
like they can do whatever the [__] they
want to do yeah but I I think that
people that
I I don't think that people with kids I
mean granted there might be a mild
pressure of like oh we're so happy and
it's kind of like a cult-like thing but
like I don't know you know that there's
some [__] arrogant ass parents that
just feel like I mean they're borderline
calling themselves astronauts because
you have no idea well you people that
don't have kids you have [__] like
they were in [__] you know fighting
in Iraq let me get the [__] out of here
with that [__] all right all right
all right but I I'll give it a blah blah
it shuts up I think they're jealous I
think that people with kids oh I wish I
was Jim Gaffigan I don't think no I
think no I'm saying people I think you
are I think people with I think people
with kids are jealous of the people that
don't have kids I think the ones that
don't want a kid
yeah I'm I am not I don't have I don't
have a dog in the fight I think you
should do what the [__] you want to do
and everybody should leave alone if
somebody teases you about what you did
it then you should laugh that's why you
should run for president
well I can run for president easy you
could easy what would be uh would you
run it I would say anybody votes me gets
a free t-shirt and that was a t-shirt
free t-shirt That'll be amazing
breathable
right you know a nice team right like a
shapely one not a boxy one no one that
you like it would it be one of those
like where men it would kind of make it
look like you you have you don't have
tits but like you have pecs
and I would just say we're going to get
down to business is going to would be my
thing no more this other stuff we're
getting down to Brass packs have you
been called uh been notified by uh by
Trump to interview Trump would you
interview Trump no and I wouldn't
interview a Democrat either I don't want
to know those people my job is to make
fun of them yeah
that's interesting yeah the same thing
with an award show why the [__] would
you have a host an award show your job
as a comic is to make fun of an award
show
why would you go there I know I mean I
shouldn't say that I mean if that's
something you want to do because that is
that is a big thing and some people are
good at it we bought it back we bought
it back yeah
no no you go you go I have to wrap this
up but yes out of all the guests I've
ever had that wore a coat in July you'll
buy far I look the things right
so you are effortless to talk about talk
with I should say to talk about yeah
we're gonna [__] on you the second no to
talk to man you just effortlessly funny
and I've just been a fan of your stand
up since I first met you and I'm just
going to keep complimenting you because
I know how uncomfortable this is for you
right yeah
just a farm boy that you know went from
Bale and hay to standing up there right
talking about the corn and the food he
made with it I love my garden yes I do I
love my garden Jim Gaffigan everybody
it's called Uh dark pale yep dark pale
on Amazon one of the best out there to
do it check it out on Amazon thank you
guys so much for watching have a
wonderful weekend you [__]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
I don't know what [__] day it was a
July 20th is that what it's going to be
is that what it's gonna be pal yeah
that's what it's gonna be
it's Sunday night
July 19th when I'm doing this I am in
Ottawa
I'm in my hotel room I am Stone sober
they have Cuban cigars here I have not
smoked one
and I'm sitting in bed right now
with a plate full of raw vegetables that
was supposed to come with hummus but
came with ranch dressing instead so I'm
trying to avoid that
so I can somehow make my goal of being
down to a buck 80 this week which I
think I am
I think I am but I don't have access to
a [__] scale here uh
that's what it is
that's where I'm at this is what boozing
and eating pizza and beer and all this
other [__] horseshit this is where it
gets you at some point you gotta pay the
piper and sit here with a bunch of
vegetables
eating this [__] crap
uh or a bunch of rabbit right now I
don't even know why it's not their fault
it's not their fault that I ate the way
I've ate like a [__] rabbit then you
know
I don't [__] know
I don't know I was so excited like a
minute ago now I'm just [__] you know
I'm just what's the point of living
[Music]
if you're not killing yourself slowly
what is the point of live what is the
point of living
think about it all this [__] that you
know what that's going to kill you
someday that's the best [__] time
right smoking drinking eating
[__] some [__] raw sorry
I need to watch my mouth there because
I'm in a nice hotel I want to disturb
the people around us
so anyways
this is just one of these deals this
sucks right now but in the morning I'm
going to be psyched
you know oh I wanted a burger oh well
Billy [__] pasty flabby tits wanted a
burger
no burger for you
there will be no burger for you I'm not
gonna eat or drink the entire podcast
but I just had some celery right
which celery I think this chemical
makeup is like air and water as far as I
know with some green dye number five
but I got one of those celery hairs in
the back of my throat right now
oh you [__] veggie [__] how do you
guys do it you know like a true
vegetarian well they don't sit around
eating this [__] they actually have
better meals
um you know
I love when you meet like a fat
vegetarian it's just like you're [__]
yourself over on two levels right now
you know what I mean it's like you're
not eating meat and that sucks and then
you're not even eating good food you're
just sitting there eating like
Doritos
it's actually good don't tell them you
know there's too many [__] people let
them die that's what I say
is that what you say oh that's what I
say on my podcast
that's what I say let the fat
vegetarians who don't know how to eat
right let them die
I implore the next leader of our great
nation of the United States of America
of America of the Americas of America
please
just let him die
okay I don't mean people with diseases
let's try to help that [__] but if you
just shoving well wait a minute maybe
that's how you got the disease because
you kept shoving [__] down your [__]
throat
let him die that's what if I was running
for president that would be my campaign
uh message and I would I would contact
Hootie and the Blowfish
and I would get those ask them if I
could have the rights to uh Let Her Cry
and I would just uh I would just have it
let let him die instead
and I I'd contact the black dude whose
name is not Hootie
was it Frank Gifford I don't know his
[__] name is what I think Frank
Gifford Dustin something or other
uh what is his [__] name I have it
Darius Rucker
right
him go and if they're eating [__]
[__] let them die oh let him drive
he did a lot of [__] wine in there
what a [__] genius that guy was he
saw the writing on the wall and he was
just like you know what we made up money
I'm [__] out and I'm African-American
and I am going I am steering my creative
ship into the overt heart of white
racism and I'm gonna put out a country
album and God damn it I'm going to be
successful and he did it
the [__] guy did it
they did the white version of that is if
you played a ukulele in one of those
[__] you know those those bands with
chicks with dirty feet sit there and
watch them after they take off their
boots and you [__] you just put out
like a a rap album
and crushed it you know and all you did
was study like he just he put on like a
trucker cap like that was his big thing
so you'd still dress the way you dressed
and you just put on like a do-rag or
something
you know and you went from singing about
the Appalachian Trail
to rap it about I don't know what what
would you rap about
how dope your ukuleles
you get your face airbrushed on the back
of it you know and just come out
you know I want to see somebody do that
go down one of those Eight Mile open
mics and I want you to come down with a
custom ukulele a do-rag white as hell
you got to be
I I was going to say at least as white
as me but I mean at that point then
you're going into albinos boy you got to
be super white I want to see good and
just see how long you can [__] lie
what's all they're going to do is Boo
come on man you can take a good bow and
right go down there and [__] have one
of your buddies airbrush yourself
and then I'm the [__] pose and just come
walking out with your do-rag and your
[__] ukulele and just have it flipped
over so they can see your face and just
have a dead serious look on your face
like you are about to blow everybody's
[__] minds
and then wrap over the ukulele and just
see how long you can go why not
why the [__] not
when in Ottawa
is that a Meg Ryan movie
is Tom Hanks is he lonely is he going to
come up and bang her out there in the
canal they never show the banging and
those Tom Hanks Meg Ryan movies that's
why they never rang true for me it's
like I get it you're fighting love and
all that but at some point
you two gotta [__]
and I'm not seeing it so I'm calling
[__]
you know more vegetables oh yeah keep
them coming
I call [__] I don't think I don't
think that Sleepless in Seattle story
ever happened
you know
why am I eating vegetables on a [__]
podcast
do you know a lot of the train
conductors they eat while they do the
announcements that's why you can't hear
them
they just shove a bunch of food in their
mouth like this
is there anything worse than a [__]
tomato
maybe they're in season up here I don't
[__] know
[__] Tomatoes man unless you pull
them out of your yard
what are you getting
all right
nobody
if you're still listening to this
I want you to call suicide hotline
oh [__] am I sober and awake
Jesus Christ
you know what you first of all I I oh I
had a rough one coming in here
um
I left
LAX oh my God I went down to LAX
to get on Air Canada
we have a leaf on the tail that
represents what our nation's about throw
in some syrup and some mild racism and a
couple of terrorists trying to cross the
border we play hockey and that ice
shovel board that I can remember the
name of who's our president
no one [__] cares
keep heading north and you'll meet Santa
Claus
or get mulled by a [__] polar bear
that [__] a grizzly bear right that's
everything I know about Canada next you
have polar bears and grizzly bears they
have [__] at this point like Tom Hanks
and Meg Ryan never did in Sleepless in
Seattle and they had a uh they had a
goal a bear or uh uh uh uh [__] uh
busy yeah you gotta go call her goal or
a pizzi that's a bad one that kid's
gonna get that little Cub's gonna get
this [__] kicked out of him at school
all right hey you're [__] different
man right
um anyways
what am I talking about
so I went to fly in right or ride in
Pilot flies I just sit in the back
riding in and uh we got out into the
tarmac
that's a word you never want to hear
during your flight the second they use
the word tarmac you're going to be
delayed at least
two hours
you may have noticed the pilot has
pulled over onto the tarmac
we're gonna be sitting we're gonna be
shutting the engines down here on the
tarmac
I don't even know what the [__]
tarmac is I have no idea what the [__]
it is all I know is that means you're
gonna sit there for two hours but
um
there was all this crazy what this crazy
[__] weather
all this thunder and lightning and all
that [__] so I'm like absolutely
pull over to the side
I'd rather sit here so um
I sat there and I don't even know what
the [__] I did
but basically I was supposed to connect
through Toronto to get here to Ottawa
and I missed that connection and uh I
was supposed to be in Ottawa by eight
o'clock and when I missed my connection
so bad that where they hooked me up on
the flight the next flight I left at 10
35 out of Toronto
um so I was brutal but I didn't die so
it's fine you know what I mean and at
the end of the day as long as it was I
still went from LA to Toronto to Ottawa
in one day which was impossible
up until a couple of decades ago right
in the 70s you couldn't do that they had
to pull over and stop
you know
fight off some indigenous people as they
tried to refuel some God forsaken place
like non-stop flights from LA to Toronto
I don't think that started until the
early 90s
as far as my Wikipedia page says
obviously I know that when was the last
time that you when are they first being
able to go from like New York to LA
without stopping I don't know Bill why
don't you look it up but I guess I don't
give a [__] I'm just talking I'm filling
up [__] time I'm filling up your
little ride to work right now huh how's
your car doing is it sputtering along is
it running good what is it doing why did
you buy that car
um
so anyways on the flight out there I
watched uh the Maltese Falcon whenever
they have that on there I love Humphrey
Bogart and if you're a a big Frank
Sinatra fan Frank was a huge fan of
Humphrey Bogart and when you watch
Humphrey Bogart you see a lot of uh
elements of his Swagger
uh in Sinatra's style and I have to tell
you right now if you're trying to quit
smoking and drinking do not
repeat do not watch The Maltese Falcon
do not watch that movie Humphrey Bogart
makes smoking and drinking look like the
greatest thing ever and before you like
oh juicy you know that guy died of
[__] lung cancer I know he smoked
camels unfiltered like a [__] chimney
do you know what else he did he became
one of the biggest stars Hollywood has
ever known
and he [__] was he hooked up with uh
was it pogi and Bacall Lauren Bacall
when she was like 19. she was like that
is a [__] Stellar human being he was
in his 40s
and they were [__] Inseparable they
loved each other he never wanted to go
out she was there's two couples that I
[__] that I love bogey Bacall and uh
Paul Newman and Joanne Woodward they
somehow they [__] made it now
obviously Bogart died so that really
helps the marriage but [__] Newman
and Woodward [__] made it
um
but anyways this [__] guy is just
rolling his own
cigarettes which wasn't bad but at one
point in the movie when he sits down
with the fat man there he hand he hands
him a [__] torpedo cigar
and if you look at the master the master
shot which is basically uh
how do I describe it Jesus Christ I've
been in a couple movies I should know
this the master shot is like whatever
the scene is that's the wide shot where
you see the where they are everybody
that's basically in the shot that is the
master shot they usually shoot that
first and then they go all right coming
around to your point of view his point
of view we're gonna do his two shot
we'll do a three-quarter do a [__]
close-up and all it's all up to the
director but the master shot if you look
at the other shots they're not smoking
but in the master shot they're actually
smoking cigars
while acting and making one of the great
movies of all [__] time it's one of
the I just that's all I think of when I
see that
I want an acting gig where I just get on
the master I get to smoke a [__]
great cigarette let me uh
it's a [__] phenomenal movie and I
think one of the most underrated actors
of all time even though he's a
considered Legend I think he's one of
the best actors of all time is uh I hope
he say his name right Peter Lawford
I think it's awesome and and the guy
plays the fat man and I should know all
these people's names he's [__]
amazing
just the sound of his voice the way he
plays it the way he's just such an even
keeled emotional person with everybody
else's kind of erratic and it's a
[__] awesome movie but if you stop
smoking and drinking I mean it's [__]
brutal that's back in the day can you
imagine back in the day like if you just
walked in to get car insurance and the
guy's sitting to cry hey you want a
drink
yeah let's [__] let's [__] do it it
just gives you a shot
there's no drinking and driving there's
no laws against it there's no
breathalyzer there's nothing there's no
airbags
[__] water's fine the [__] food
hasn't been genetically altered you just
walk in places and hey you want
something you want to smoke in a drink
back then you weren't an addict you were
just considered an adult
if you couldn't get your [__] together
he's a drunk he's a town drunk he's a
[__] wino
get your [__] together right now
everybody's a [__] addict and it
isn't their fault
I don't know I I guess I understand that
um
with drug I certainly understand that
with drugs and alcohol
I've lost some friends to that [__] but
I gotta say with the food stuff
you know I I don't know about that one
it's just kind of like
just eat a salad my oversimplify it
really is I guess that's saying to an
alcoholic just don't drink but you
really just gotta like I'm trying to say
this in an empowering way like tonight I
wanted a burger I wanted the [__]
ribs I wanted all of that [__] and I
just you just got to get past that dumb
thought and think like do I really want
to have to do do I like going to the gym
no
do I want to go on the elliptical for
the rest of my life no
just throw a couple of celery sticks
down your [__] pie hole and then that
that craving will be like right now I'm
not even thinking about a steak all I'm
thinking right now is how awful
vegetables taste
you know what I'll be fine what look at
my options cauliflower if I was a
vegetable I'd be cauliflower
isn't that sad like the ugliest
vegetable there is
I had a green one the other day you know
something if I wasn't so stoic I'd start
[__] crying right now just the last
couple of days of eating it's been
[__] brutal however
um that's not what I came here to talk
about everybody I came here to talk
about
um
how I was in Ottawa tonight and it's
hilarious my agent goes to me goes hey
before you do the Montreal Comedy
Festival on Monday this is gig
um
this Blues Festival in Ottawa deep
purple's gonna be there yeah yeah all
that type of [__] so I go yeah man [__]
it I'll do that when I was in Reno there
was a Blues Festival
all of a sudden I don't know about a
week it was like months ago about a week
out I the [__] word comes in
that uh
that it's actually it's outside and I'm
gonna be going on in between bands I'm
like what the [__] so I call it my age
and I was just like dude I'm not trying
to be a diva here but uh
didn't we already pay these dues I
thought I already I already did these I
did these gigs to not have to do them
again right
he's like no no it's gonna be great it's
going to be great sagitt did it last
year he had a great [__] time and I'm
like this thing is outside
yes it's outside I go on in between
bands yes you go on in between bands
and I'm like and it's good and he's like
yes it's good trust me it's good now I
assume most of you guys will listen to
this are not stand-up comedians but any
stand-up comic who's listening to this
right now is like going Let's either
laughing or going no don't take the gig
so I [__] show up
and um
you know Weird Al Yankovic had gone on
like at like five in the afternoon when
it was hot as [__] he's putting on all
these [__] costumes and stuff
so he's laughing about it and we're
having the and I'm standing there
looking out in the crowd and uh
Bachmann Turner overdrives playing on
the other side it's one of those things
where they got two stages going when
they finished then I go up and then the
next band so they're out there and I'm
just looking at a bunch there's no
chairs
it's the summer so it's still [__]
you know broad daylight and it's [__]
muggy as [__]
you know and I guess Bachman's the only
guy left and he's on the other side of
the [__] parking lot
every morning from alarm clocks four to
take to 8 15 through the city and I'm
just sitting there taking this all in
going I am going to eat my [__] ball
I'm gonna bomb
this is gonna be a [__] nightmare
and Al's going out of that good they're
good so uh
anyways
they end up bringing me up this radio
guy brings me up [__] amazing voice
well let's listen to what I want to fly
that guy sounds like amazing right
brings me up and I come walking out
there and uh the whole crowd cheered
and it was ended up being this [__]
amazing show and I was really kind of
waiting for it to uh
in the first eight minutes I was waiting
for it to go bad and it was [__]
amazing and then I was outside and I
started thinking about Robin Williams uh
uh all those shows he did performing for
the troops those were outside
and uh I don't know in the middle of it
I got like about 10 minutes in I got
inspired to like really
quit being a [__] baby about this
thing
um
because you know you get out there you
know if you think somebody's coming at
you want to start [__] lashing out of
people before they get you and
everything and uh reminds me of this
this fave there's this famous story
about Robin Williams
um Joe bartnick told me it and uh
you know he was royalty
um Robin Williams in uh San Francisco
so I guess there was some sort of
concert that was supposed to happen some
huge band and everyone's standing
outside you know
some giant [__] venue waiting to see
this band but it started raining and
lightning and all this [__] so the band
couldn't go on and everybody was getting
upset but I guess Robin Williams was in
the crowd was there for the show
and he just said [__] it and went on
stage for like an hour or an hour and a
half and just did a off the you know
the top of his head comedy show [__]
destroyed and in the end of his show the
sun started coming out the crowd went
[__] nuts and then he brought the
band on and
um
I don't know he told me that stuff
that's one of the coolest [__] things
ever you know somewhere in the middle of
it I started thinking about this that
that story but anyways I want to thank
everybody from Ottawa
um on in in and around Ottawa who came
out to the show you guys had no chairs
you stood up for an hour I had a [__]
great time
and uh while I was doing it the sun was
going down and the sky was amazing
I kept making fun of that like I would
be in the middle of a joke right tell a
joke yes my [__] wife about to go oh
God how great was that breeze I was
saying all this [__] I'd never said in
23 years on stage how great was that how
great is the breeze
uh look at those clouds somebody take a
picture and share that was it was Unreal
it was a phenomenal gig and
to make it even even better
was uh believe it or not the uh
um the company that we hired to animate
F is for family which is coming out in
December
is actually in Ottawa so I went over
there today and I met everybody and they
were all cool as hell and young and they
thought the show was [__] hilarious
and it wasn't like anything they had
ever seen
so and I and I met this
this one woman who was I'm not I'm not
giving away any of the show but was
animating this really [__] up scene
and I was laughing that she got to see
just because of what the scene was about
her being a woman and she said and I was
like how did you end up getting this she
said I actually requested it I wanted to
animate this scene and I gotta tell you
guys I don't talk any [__]
I'm not sure who's came to I [__] around
but I'd like when I talk about my career
I don't talk about any [__] but I will
just say this I was very
very excited
when I left those Studio that studio
today and I think I think this show is
going to be I think this is the one as
far as
I found the right thing where I can be
funny the way I'm funny and stand up and
funny on the [__] podcast I can be
that kind of funny
on TV
um so
I don't even feel like I'm jinxing it
I'm one of those [__] old ladies like
don't say that then you're gonna [__]
jinx it I think it's [__] it's really
coming out well I'm trying to [__]
not be too [__] excited but uh just
do me do me a solid you guys when that
[__] thing comes out just watch it
on Netflix just [__] watch it so we
get good numbers because uh and then if
you like it please tell some other
people I don't think I'm gonna have to
ask you to do that after you watch it
I'm just saying that right now oh
Billy's talking a little [__] here
talking a little bit of [__]
um
then that's all I [__] need right I
do stand up and then I do this [__]
off the wall cartoon
I call it a day
call it a day
do a good five seasons of that and then
I [__] happy trails I go by my
[__] Ranch in Alabama
I'll see you get the NHL package the MLB
package the [__] uh the [__]
whatever the basketball one is I'll get
the college one too I'll get the [__]
end League Pass NFL pass whatever the
[__] it is I'm getting all of those
all right
and then I'm getting me a case of
[__] bear
that's it I'm getting me a case of
[__] beer
and then I'm gonna [__]
I'm gonna join the clan when I'm down
there and I'm gonna see it I'm gonna be
like see if I can like talk people out
of it
show up to meetings and sort of not as
people are talking and just sort of be
like that you know I mean I'm just
dealing they're not that bad come on you
know just I'm just saying I'm just
saying
and you know what's funny that's what
every group needs even if you have a
good cause you need somebody in there
that does not share your point of view
because if you don't you go off the
[__] rails
that's what the clan needs the clan
needs some members that don't hate black
people
just to [__] spin them back into
reality
wouldn't you think like these feminist
groups that's what the [__] they need
they need some [__] jerk-off guy like
me in there just to [__] you know
you can't you can't be in a group where
everybody thinks the same way you spin
off down the [__] real it's it's like
when conspiracy theorists get together a
[__] eyebrows shoot up to the ceiling
next thing you know what we're we're
talking about yeah everything was an
inside job you need somebody there to be
like guys guys guys do you realize how
many people would have to be involved to
pull that off and everybody keeps their
[__] mouth shut
and then you could be oh you know what
you're right you're right we got a
little out of hand there we got a little
out of hand
maybe I'll drive by heckling Clan
meetings in the south
just drive by they're not that bad if
you got to know some people
I wouldn't agree with that I have
experiences that are like that you know
just freaking out
anyways
um I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about let's do some reads this
week
um [__] DraftKings has been breaking
my balls
just breaking my [__] balls
I love DraftKings I don't know what
they're [__] they don't like that I
make a joke that they're a [__]
gambling website
they don't like it
I keep getting like I got a text they
they said earlier this week just you
know we love the reads just don't say
that we're a gambling website just say
that we're it's more of a skill based
thing
it's just like what what are you talking
about it's like
you're gambling you've combined uh
fantasy baseball or fantasy football
with with the Vegas Sportsbook we're all
adults
I don't have a problem with it
why can't you just be who you are
DraftKings
this is the [__] letter I got here
where is it here
all right uh
okay just just sent saying the
advertising did you see the email
regarding DraftKings please remind Bill
not Capital not to compare DraftKings to
gambling
well
I don't I don't [__] get people that
first of all gambling is legal it's
legal what you're doing is [__] legal
why are you ashamed it's like saying you
know we're not having sex we're just
seeing how our bodies fit together
right
that's probably a bad example
I gamble
you know the Pete Rose joke not only is
it funny it [__] makes sense
so I'm going to continue to read it the
way I always [__] read it and you
know if you don't like it then I guess
you know go to another podcast I don't
know what the [__] to tell you
this isn't like radio I can't get fired
from my own [__] show
[__] skill based thing that's what
kills me that you're sitting there as
[__] adults and you can just sit
there and say that lie unless you sat
there in the meeting and you went like
listen guys this is just bad for
business to say that this is a gambling
website so let's hope Bill is dumb
enough
to go along with it's more of a skill
based [__] thing well I'm gonna keep
reading it the way I read it what about
the Howard Cosell thing that I do you
don't like that
if I don't make these things [__]
entertaining advertising people people
just gonna
[__] fast forward through
listen if me undies can roll with sweaty
balls and no sweaty clam I think he can
handle a Pete Rose joke
we're all adults here we know what they
are it's more of a skill based [__]
thing that's what they used to say in
the football card when I was in high
school when they had when the book he'd
give you that on the back it says not to
be used for gambling it's just a skill
based game we all know what's going on
all right
there we go that's like the two people
at the office who are [__] and they
think nobody knows everybody knows all
right just [__] drop your pants and
go at it 37 minutes in I'll tell you
time flies when you're just Stone sober
eating vegetables at 10 [__] 52 at
night
Jesus Christ
oh my God what am I I'm in two weeks in
two weeks in it's just hard at night if
you notice when I do the podcast in the
morning or in the afternoon
I'm in a good [__] mood this is when
it's the hardest
you know
your body's starting to shut down and
the devil's starting to wake up like hey
what are we doing
fresh milk California you ain't no
[__] eat no vegetables
um all right let's let's get to some of
the reads here
have I talked about everything I wanted
to talk about here the [__] else did I
want to mentioned
um
oh oh Jesus Christ I almost forgot uh
one of the guys that basically taught me
how to be a comedian
unfortunately passed away uh 73 years of
age Bob Seibel I was laid to rest today
and I just wanted to make sure that I
took time
to mention uh what a [__] great guy
he was man just such a great guy he was
always cool to me when I started out and
just such a um I mean I didn't even know
all this [__] about I'm gonna read this
this link here
when they talked about
um
Bob Seibel uh he started
um in 1979 that was the start of a
36-year career in stand-up comedy from a
guy whom his good friend and fellow
comedian Mike McDonald who's another
[__] hilarious comic called a
fantastic Maniac on stage Bob made you
laugh off stage he was gen he genuinely
cared about people and uh this this is
what I found amazing about this guy and
actually I kind of related to it where
he was into a bunch of different [__]
um
let's see where the [__] is it
not Christ Bill why don't you you're
giving a tribute to the guy and you're
gonna [__] this whole thing up well you
know what you're gonna have to deal with
me reading out loud here uh those who
knew cybell are aware that his life was
lived in two distinct Parts with January
5th 1977 serving as the as the line of
demarcation I hope I said that right
that's the day he gave up drinking
driving into an occupied park car on
Market Street was the final straw and
while his post-drinking life was not
much longer in years 38 versus 35 he was
determined to live every day like it was
like he was trying to make up for lost
time uh
and they say basically the guy in the
Dos Equis commercial the most
interesting man in the world doesn't
have anything on Bob's side belt now I
know what you're thinking what the [__]
does that mean here you go where do you
start cybell ran more than 30 marathons
this is a monster headline comic he also
ran more than 30 marathons including the
Boston Marathon 17 times he was a
certified scuba diver who dived you know
he did cruises he did he [__] Dove
all over the world an artist a musician
an airplane pilot he hiked the
Appalachian Trail several times climbed
Mount kill him Kilimanjaro
he went on transatlantic cruises though
not in the traditional manner he would
travel on Cargo in Steam ships and was
often the only one on the ship not
working it was his economical way to see
the world
uh that was far from the only traveling
he did in the last 11 years since he and
his loving companion reconnected they
dated in high school and lost touch for
44 years the pair traveled to China
Italy Morocco Greece turkey Ukraine
France Spain England Ireland Iceland the
Bahamas and Canada let me tell you
something dude that's the way to be a
[__] comedian
is once you're a headlining comic and
you're telling [__] jokes and people
are coming out to see you why you would
ever get yourself sucked into the
industry
when you can do all of this [__]
how [__] amazing is that he he [__]
around for the first 35 years of his
life and was still able to do that and I
gotta tell you man he was one of the
greatest [__] guys and uh when I
started out I know I've mentioned this
before
um
I started out in March of 1992 and the
big 80s common comedy boom was crashing
hard and there was a lot of guys that
worked in the 80s they they basically
they had more
more rooms than actual bona fide
comedians so what happened was I came in
during the trimming the fat ears
so obviously I did not start off in the
greatest rooms and I ran into some of
these bitter guys that were coming back
down and had to get day jobs and they
were some of them
were some of the worst [__] people
you'd ever want to meet I forgive them
because they were [__] dealing with
you know what they were going through
but some of them I mean I know guys
would be like hey you know
look at this look at this it's Wednesday
night you know [__] three years ago
there'd be a line around the block
there's barely anybody here and I had a
guy one time say that to me and say you
know what if I if I would start now now
I'd quit man I'd get into something else
I was literally trying to discourage me
that's how desperate this person was and
um
cybelle was not one of those guys man he
was just a great guy really was
interested in in who you were and what
you did and all that and uh he lived a
hell of a life
uh that's another great thing I'll post
the the uh this article one of the
coolest things anybody could ever say
about you they said Bob seibel's Bucket
List was empty so
um
I don't know I definitely just wanted
you guys to know who that guy was he was
a [__] great dude man
all right so anyways let's get on to
your questions here for the week for the
week for the week for the week where the
hell do I go here sorry I'm on my iPad
I'm on my mini iPad it's like it's big
but it's small you know what I mean
all right
um
okay once again people
um if you want to email me and ask me
questions the email is Bill at the
mmpodcast.com
um Boston posters are still on sale as
of now there's 175 left I know I had a
lot of problems with the website but you
know me with technology
um also I'm supposed to remind you guys
about bethematch.org
bethematch.org it's a the bone marrow
registry you give bone marrow you can
save somebody's life uh we've had a few
listeners that respond that joined the
registry uh at the B match and tweeted
us at what a great experience it was all
right
there you go that's that's good karma
too I would have a horrific thing you do
this weekend you want to balance it out
you can go do that all right Galaxy
search as I mentioned I was looking for
a Ford Galaxy my wife is kind of making
me being a little more smart about it
but uh
I already have one [__] old vehicle
that I got to get fixed all the time
she's right
well you know maybe he needs a friend
anyways this guy said hey Bill if you
want to search Craigslist nationwide for
that Galaxy try search tempest
so there you go that's for you guys
whatever the [__] you're looking for uh
www.searchtempis.com all right here we
go let's get to the questions for the
week here
um new fan from Norway
j-u-p-p jump that's right new fan it's
possible great podcast great shows well
thank you sir our ma'am
um I've seen all your clips on YouTube
in the last couple of days now summer
holidays at the cabins raining so thank
you you saved it uh pardon my English
but how's your new Norwegian right you
know what you got me there you're way
better than I am I don't know anything
other than tuck which means thank you
um so somebody could be like hey can I
shoot you in the head I'll be like thank
you yes absolutely keep on doing
whatever you're doing it works and when
you come back when are you coming back
to Oslo uh because I know you I see
you've been here I've been there twice
my friend next time call me
it gives the phone number and he goes
not gay I love when guys do that not gay
like what if you were
that they like I like
whatever move you made I would hey dude
I'm not gay you're sorry man but you
know I'm flattered
then it would be over
then we go cross-country skiing or
whatever I can handle it if you gay no
big deal I promise he said I promise I
can I can take you on a local to a local
soccer game anyways best regards blah
blah blah
uh uh oh his name's Glenn named after
Glenn Anderson from the Gretzky line uh
from his Edmonton Oiler years true my uh
my dad's work
what
valeriega Red Sox Rangers New York
Giants L Beckham Jr
will own 2015-16 you know what dude you
went off the rails with your your
English I don't know what happened there
but you know what
most important thing when am I going
back over there uh probably next year
um I think the last time I was there was
the end of 2013 so I am more than
overdue because I could go there right
now and give you guys all brand new
hours worth of jokes so uh and I think
this team this time when I go over there
I'm going to add some Eastern European
countries
and uh
I don't know I'm looking forward to it
definitely looking forward to it last
time I went to Oslo I met this [__]
badass dude who was shredded was this
little guy who had the most sickest
[__] beard he just did not shave and
his beard went from just under his eyes
downed and met his chest here this guy
was a [__] animal and uh he'd just
come back from Thailand where two months
out of every year this guy goes over
there and just
gets taught by these Masters and gets
the [__] kicked out of him and comes
back here like a [__] comes back to
Norway just absolutely shredded and even
more of a deadly weapon than he was when
he left
um
those are the kinds of people that I
like those are the kinds of people that
you should meet because that's the kind
of [__] like you listen like dude you
can do that you can just leave what you
live for two [__] months go to the
other side of the planet and fight for
two months and it's like yeah if you set
your life up always working towards that
your life ends up going around that [__]
so if you're young right now you know
when you're sitting there you're getting
ready to get out of college and the
whole cubicle life is scaring you you
can set it up however you want to set it
up just start
doing the [__] that you want to do and
then your life sort of builds around it
all right so anyways all right weight
loss challenge
hey they have freckles I love the
podcast and been trying to get motivated
to at least not be that fat I'm from
Wisconsin so beer and cheese curds are
like appetizers before more beer and
meats with fried cheeses
ah god dude you know how hard that is to
read right now you know how [__]
great that sounds
oh my God I'd kill for any of that right
now uh he goes I'm five nine 218 pounds
big boy
dude you are you're you're like fourth
and goal weight
and give it to you you'll get it in
there man
five nine two eighteen that's pretty
[__] solid my friend and he said oh
how many [__] hoodies do you own he
goes I've always been active and play
sports there you go so there's muscle
underneath there you you're gonna
[__] destroy somebody if you start
playing rugby
um he said I've always been active and
play sports
after your last Monday Morning podcast I
was asked by some co-worker if I wanted
to be there fourth in a relay Marathon
because of your recent fat motivation
towards yourself and challenge I am
doing it all right good for you said
this chubby John Stockton perhaps beer
loving bastard has already ran 13 miles
this week already and is cut down on the
PBR switching to PBR Light thanks for
the encouragement all right good field
yeah dude that's the one thing I have
noticed since trying to lose weight is
uh Runners are [__]
they're all [__] skinny you don't see
a lot of fat Runners unless somebody's
fat and they decided to run other than
that it just sort of melts off of you my
only thing is I don't know how their
feet and knees can take it in their back
and everything like that
um I got this weird thing where I can
sort of run on a treadmill a little bit
but if I run outside if I run on a
sidewalk like I'll go half a block on my
knees or like hey hey hey easy easy what
are we doing here what are we doing
all right get on the grass and start
walking so
my biggest thing that I'm doing is I'm
just changing the way I eat um who's
kidding who I'm taking a break from the
way I eat I'm always gonna have steaks
and [__] like that but uh
oh God damn it look at this I have three
pieces of cauliflower
I got like
a
two carrots
three little those round [__]
tomatoes and a couple pieces of broccoli
is there's nothing I love broccoli if
it's stained but if it's completely
[__] raw it is practically impossible
to eat
and you know what's even harder
is to eat it and actually do you know do
a podcast
I bet this has never been done
has anybody ever just taken a big
[__] thing of cauliflower or shoved
it in their mouth and tried to read an
email
on a podcast podcasting is so young you
know I don't think it's been done this
is like eating a [__] raw broccoli
with nothing on it this is like you know
that cinnamon challenge and like a
vegetarian way here we go this is so
gross
look at the top of broccoli it's like
you know those people with gross tongues
all those little bumps on the [__]
tongues it's just this is [__] nasty
ah
oh my God
I don't eat an ironing board but I think
this is what it would [__] taste like
this isn't even food
this is a [__] grossest thing
oh my God
oh this is [__] horrible
broccoli two thumbs down
you know broccoli is like part of a
comedy team like I think when comedy
they have to be part of a team there's
no [__] way this thing could go on
stage by itself and hold a crop
holy [__]
another thing too is it never [__]
ends
you will chew broccoli for like four
[__] hours
oh God
all right
Jesus Christ
um anyways
why did I do this I still have two
[__] cheeks full of this ship
it looks like a ball player in the
[__] 70s and 80s instead of tobacco
it's broccoli that'd be great if you
joined a baseball team they're all
putting my [__] dip in back in the
day and you're sticking like broccoli in
there like what are you doing oh yes
little broccoli it's good fiber
it's good for your prostate
keeps things moving
is it good for your prostate I don't
know it's not good for your mouth I can
tell you that
ah
do it do it through it
I never make noises like this when I'm
eating steak that's all I'm saying
you know
you eat steak here oh you [__]
dropped the fork unless it's a [__] one
you know what I mean
here's a good here's a good rule of
thumb if you walk into a steakhouse and
they have steak sauce on the table you
turn around you walk the [__] up
all right a good steak just not just
[__] [__] end it all right
how long does this take
all right there we go
you know what's funny that man versus
food I never saw him eat broccoli I know
why
I know it sucked towards the end of the
challenge but he always enjoyed the
beginning all right sorry about that
guys that was a bad [__] idea
holy [__]
oh the only thing worse than that would
be eating like a mouthful of hair
all right badass Russian pilot oh you
guys got to see this video
you got to see this video
um
I actually got her name
she's
um her name is
Svetlana how great is that name
right
um
dear Bill the red bur on oh like the Red
Baron I get it Ah that's not bad since
you're a pilot now I thought you might
find this video interesting even though
I had my license I do not consider
myself I mean I am a novice dude I'm
still [__] learning here obviously
okay the Russian pilot is considered uh
the pilot of the century
um oh she's considered the pilot of the
century according to RT News
she is one of the world's most honored
aeronauts check out the video below it's
a cockpit view of her flying acrobatics
around the Black Sea
um look wise she is a Russian seven but
when you factor in her pilot skills she
becomes a perfect 10.
um well Russian seven is a [__] at
least an eight and a half or a nine
anywhere else in the world they're
gorgeous
um seriously though this video shows
that the Soviets were onto something
when they used women as combat pilots in
World War II I didn't know that by the
way
the Germans didn't have a chance against
the night witches I gotta look some [__]
up on that I hope my internet came back
these [__] [__] I paid for it
here let's see here Knight witches I
gotta read about this but watch the
video we'll post it and um
the [__] that this person is doing
is
like just the level of geez like you
ever see those guys like when they just
auditioning to see if they can be a Jet
Pilot
and you know they sent him around that
[__] whatever it's like that that
carnival ride that you always go on
except it's way faster and they end up
like passing out and [__] how she
doesn't pass out
and um
and knows where the hell she's going I
actually got dizzy watching it she's
she's [__] unbelievable all right
night witches everybody
um night witches is the English
translation of
um some [__] German word that I can't
[__] pronounce a World War Two German
nickname
um for the female mil uh female military
aviators of the 588th night bomber
regiment known as the 46th
Tom and Guy blah blah blah how come they
haven't made a movie about this it's
because it's the Russians in the Cold
War
Jesus Christ
this has Meryl Streep written all over
it
you know they wanted to do it and
instead they did A League of Their Own
because the [__] wall hadn't come
down in Germany yet
it's a [__] amazing this amazing uh
it should be a movie
they must have made one already the
regiment flew harass harassment bombing
and precision bombing missions against
the German military from 1942 to the end
of the war
all right this is creepy how did the
Germans know that it was a guy or a
woman
you know what happened is they shot one
down they ran over to see if they were
still alive and if they were they killed
them and then in the end they realized
it was a woman
how the [__] did they I never understood
that how you got to know your enemy that
well
like you knew you knew that that was the
like when they're dropping bombs on you
you're sticking your head out yeah it
looks like the 588th night bomber
regiment
on so sassy [__]
all right the night regimen all right
blah blah blah they threw over four 800
missions by the end of the war and 23
having been awarded 23 of them were
awarded the hero of the Soviet Union
title 30 of its members died in combat
um the regiment flew in wood and canvas
biplanes oh that's why
ah Jesus they [__] him over they
didn't give them the nice planes
a 1928 design intended for use is
training aircraft and for crop dusting
and to this day the most produced
biplane in all of Aviation oh my God
dude Joseph style he didn't give a [__]
he'd sacrifice a 200 000 [__] out of his
own goddamn people to get another 100
yards
you didn't give a [__] and put the
broads up in those old [__] plates do
it or I'll [__] have you killed
it worked all right
it worked he beat their [__] asses
couldn't beat the people in Finland
though could he
I still have those [__]
broccoli [__] in my mouth I'm gonna read
more about that man that's very
interesting thank you for that email
all right what are we up to 58 minutes
all right let's get in the last [__]
thing here let's get the last [__]
read in here
um
all right girlfriend with too many guy
friends
Jesus Christ
I'm sorry I'm still dealing with the
broccoli here a girlfriend with too many
guy friends hey old Dr Bill
I'm a 21 year old college student and I
started dating this girl at my school
five months ago things seem to be going
great but unfortunately we've been away
from each other this summer because
we're from different states
we talk almost every day but there are
some days when I never hear from her at
all I just see her posting different
things she does with their friends on
social media I would have a problem with
I wouldn't have a problem with it except
hang on a second what the [__] broccoli
it's just never done
um sorry guys I promise I won't eat
again on the podcast it's really rude I
I know I know it's horrible sorry uh we
talked about but I wouldn't have a
problem with the except the majority of
the time it's with a group of dudes
she's always hanging out with about five
of her friends who are all guys and then
a handful of times there's other girls
there every time I see her post
something about them I feel jealous and
angry that she's spending all this time
with other guys not only that but her
most recent post was on a boat with all
these guys wearing prop wearing probably
her most revealing bikini
I haven't met any of these guys so I
definitely don't trust any of them and
whenever she's with them and I text her
she takes hours to respond or even waits
to the next day I I want to bring it up
how I feel about that but I don't want
to make it feel like I'm telling her who
she can and can to hang out with so what
do you think I should do bring it up
um that I don't like how she hangs out
with other guys or just shut the [__] up
and trust that she's not up to anything
it would be great to hear from Nia
thanks uh what Nia thinks to get a
female perspective too I wish she was
here right now because uh you're going
to get my perspective um anyway sorry
for the long email hopefully it didn't I
didn't use too many big words for you
yeah go [__] yourself
um
what do I think about that uh yeah
that's kind of weird
I mean what would she think if you were
[__] hanging out with like five other
broads and you were wearing a speedo
when you got didn't get back to her the
next day she'd probably think that you
were [__] around right
so I would just I would just say to us
Hey listen I'm not trying to be a jerk
here but uh
you know when you post you know when
you're hanging out you seem to only be
hanging out with other guys you're on
boats you're wearing skimpy bikinis it's
it's making me feel uncomfortable here
all right she's like
and just go look I'm just communicating
that it it kind of makes me
uncomfortable
um
yeah this is real difficult Without You
seeming like you're [__] checking in
on her and being like a jerk but just
just ask her just so let me ask you this
if you know if I if I text you and I
didn't get back if you text me and I
didn't get back to you for a full
[__] 24 hours
all right
and then you see a picture on Facebook
and I'm standing in with my ball bag all
in a bunch you know all wadded up like a
[__] packed parachute
laughs
hanging out with like five chicks on a
boat
I mean wouldn't you kind of be like you
know dude what the [__]
just ask her am I out of line here
then also tell her too and please tell
me
you know if you're not feeling it
anymore and you want to hook up with
other guys just let me know early on
so you know the heartache is way less
just let me know
all right but uh dude I don't think that
it's weird that you're uncomfortable
with that that is [__] weird
um
you know hanging out with five guys and
your most revealing [__] bikini give
me you know what the [__] you doing
no those are just my guy friends
all right now I'm getting annoyed huh
what are you a [__] attention [__]
what's going to say all the [__] that
you can't say to him this is all the
[__] you're thinking and you're totally
justified to think of it and don't
listen to any [__] broad to tell you
anything different because if you were
doing it they give you the exact same
[__] [__] all right I got my footing
on this one all right just ask her just
ask her what is what's you know
don't steal it in the tone that I'm
doing it but you got to ask what the
[__] going on here
you know
honey with all due respect I mean you
[__] it looks like you you're in a
sausage Factory there
you know wearing your little skimpy
[__] outfit what's going on they be
one thing if you were there with one of
your girlfriends and even then I'm
thinking a little five on two action
right what's going on
I don't know what to tell you dude
that's that's a [__] up situation uh
it might be just how she likes she may
be always good I don't like other girls
I don't get along with other girls she
may be one of those [__] people
well really you like hanging out with
guys well why don't you do it with some
[__] clothes on how about that you
know how about this can we can we make a
rule that uh you know you gotta put on
some [__] clothes when you hang out
with these guys
how about that because you know you're
just gonna get pissed and then you're
gonna start hanging out with some chicks
and just to piss her off you're gonna
start taking [__] pictures and not
return her [__] text for a day and
you start doing that childish [__]
rather than just getting right to the
[__] me to the heart of the matter
there right the meat of the matter look
at this that's how much instead of
saying the heart I said the meat that's
how much I'm [__] hating these
vegetables
oh Jesus yeah
um anyways people if you enjoy this
podcast
all right and you'd like to donate
without having to donate next time
you're gonna buy something on amazon.com
go to billboard.com click on the
merchandise page click on the Amazon uh
[__] link and it just takes you right
there and I get credit for driving
traffic to their site they kick me a
little dough it doesn't cost you any
extra [__] money if you don't want to
do it I completely understand
um so anyways that is the podcast for
this week
um I'm happy to be [__] Stone sober
and getting in shape uh but tonight was
a bad one I probably should have been
more uplifting for people who are trying
to do it you're going to have these
[__] nights but I will tell you this
I am
I'm gonna finish this [__] plate a
[__] broccoli and cauliflower and all
that horseshit and tomorrow morning you
know what as much as this sucks I'm
gonna feel like a million bucks and my
stomach's gonna be a little flatter
right
you got to be willing to sacrifice
oh Jesus Christ I I you know what I'm so
[__] bummed out right now I can't
even [__] uh I actually know it's
funny Once the English people told me
that bummed out means you got [__] in
the ass I I can't even say that anymore
what what what's what what is the real
word that I'm trying to say
I'm a little Melancholy right now
I'm Melancholy with the cauliflower
um anyways sorry about that uh that's
the podcast for this week as always
thanks for listening everybody in Ottawa
that showed up man that was [__] cool
as [__] man to actually perform outside
I have a whole new
um
perspective on it it made me think of
that cool [__] story Joe bartnick
told me about Robin Williams and it
actually uh
I don't know kind of reminded me like
hey you know
you were put here to do this so quit
your [__] whining
you know what's the matter it's not a
perfect situation you [__] baby get
out there and give them a goddamn show
and then you have a great [__] time
it was awesome it was [__] awesome so
thank you to everybody in Ottawa and uh
now it's on to Montreal the Montreal
Comedy Festival and I'm doing three
goddamn comedy jams and I'm doing three
stand-up uh shows
um
and uh we're gonna be up there with the
lovely Nia
and we're going to be enjoying Montreal
I'm doing three songs
playing drums for three [__] songs
and I was actually putting my putting
pressure on myself for that like [__]
practicing and all that [__] then I
finally remembered like hey isn't
playing drums just something you do for
fun bill why don't you work a little
more on the stand up back Decay instead
of the [__] so whatever so I'm
probably gonna [__] up I know I'm gonna
[__] up the songs
uh in some way shape or form but I'm
gonna have a good time so uh that is it
uh that's a podcast for this week go
[__] yourselves I'll talk to you next
week